大家好,我是蒋明洋,来自于蚂蚁蜜酸科技
今天跟大家分享的是可行数据空间中的连接器
我今天分享的内容主要包括三部分
第一部分会介绍一下相关的背景知识
第二部分会介绍一下连接器包含的功能
第三部分会介绍一下连接器的技术架构
首先是第一部分是关于可行数据空间的一个背景介绍
首先可行数据空间它在国家数据计划设施中的位置
我们来一起看一下
可行数据空间它是我们国家数据计划设施中的一部分
是符合国家数据计划设施的整体的架构及基本的约束的
左侧这张图就是数据基础设施整体的架构图
然后国家数据计划设施当中
其实它定义了几个核心的概念
包括权域的功能节点
区域和行业的功能节点
以及业务节点
加往下是连接器
我们先看一下权域的功能节点
它其实指的是数据基础设施中面向权域的
用一个统一的标识管理
统一的身份管理
统一的目录管理
这就是之前可能其他课程当中介绍到的三统一
然后第二个就是区域的功能节点
它在数据基础设施当中
是面向一个特定区域提供身份的注册
核验和数据的登记
数据目录的查询
数据标识的解析
以及运行监测等服务的节点
行业的功能节点和区域的功能节点的功能类似
只不过是它面向的是特定的行业
区域功能节点面向的是特定的区域
然后是业务节点
业务节点它是数据基础设施中的各区域行业
和企业的数据流通利用平台
是提供数据采集
数据加工 数据交易
数据开发等功能的这样的一个服务节点
可信数据空间
其实就是作为国家数据基础设施中的业务节点
在这张图可以看到
可信数据空间要包括
可信数据空间服务平台
以及接入的连接器
和国家数据基础设施中的业务节点
是对等的
接入连接器
可信数据空间的接入连接器
是对数据基础设施当中的
接入连接器的一个扩展
下面会展开来介绍一下
就是可信数据空间当中的
可信数据空间服务平台
以及接入连接器
可信数据空间
里边的可信数据空间服务平台
它其实主要是按照三统一的要求
保持身份标识目录
与区域行业功能节点的互联互通
可信数据空间服务平台
与其他的流通
利用平台里边的业务节点
也是要能够互联互通的
在实际的数据流通利用业务中
以按需附用其他业务节点的功能
向数据交易
开发应用中心
数据托管
存证审计等
也可以根据实际的业务需求
然后去扩展一些相应的功能
然后它的整体的价格图
就是我们左侧这张图
这张图也是从
可信数据空间技术交求里边
结过来的
可以看到就是可信数据空间服务平台
它其实在这个地方
然后它向上是对接了
行业或者区域的功能节点
与这个功能节点
提供统一的身份
统一的标识和统一的目录
东西下又去和其他的流通
利用的业务平台
能够保持互联互通和能力的附用
然后向下是可以允许
可信数据空间中的接入连接器
能够接入到
可信数据空间的服务平台里边
接入连接器又是和数据提供方
数据使用方进行使用的
数据提供方或者数据使用方
可以通过连接器来接入
可信数据空间的服务平台
然后可信数据空间服务平台
又包括身份管理
接入连接器的管理
目录管理以及可信数据空间的管理
这些是空间服务平台提供的功能
然后我们今天重点介绍的是
可信数据空间里边的接入连接器
那接入连接器它是用于
用户接入可信数据空间
服务平台的可以访问和使用
可信数据空间资源的入口
接入连接器加入可信数据空间
使应该遵循这个NDITR
相关文件中的要求并能够
采取了一些扩展的方式的
接入连接器
其中扩展的功能就是
这边扩展的功能指的是
可信数据空间里边的
接入连接器叫
国家数据基础设施里边的
接入连接器进行了一些功能的扩展
扩展项主要是包括
像数据交付,数据资源的管理
数据产品的管理
数字合约的管理
数据使用控制等五个功能
这些功能是
可信数据空间里边的
接入连接器独有的一些功能
然后具体的架构
它是在左侧这张图里边
也就是使用方和停用方
通过联系能够接入
可信空间服务平台
然后可信空间服务平台
又对上通过统一标识
统一身份,统一目录
统一接口的方式
能够去连到数据基础设施
当中的功能节点
对,他们大概是一个这样的关系
那接下来我会展开来
详细介绍一下
就是连接器
它具体包含了哪些功能
首先连接器
就是蚂蚁密算这边的连接器
其实它实现的功能
就是基于可信数据空间的技术架构
这个技术文件中的
对连接器要求去实现的
基于这个文件当中
连接器的要求去实现的
所以我们的蚂蚁密算的连接器
也是包括了这六大的功能
分别是身份管理
数据资源的管理
数据产品的管理
数字合约的管理
数据交付
数据的使用控制
那接下来我会分别的
针对每一个功能
进行一个展开的介绍
第一个是连接器的
功能是身份管理
身份管理包括几部分
第一个是用户的身份管理
那用户的身份管理
这个非常好理解
就是提供了用户能够
通过用户名和账密
能够登录到连接器
同时呢
就是可以对这个
联系里面的用户
进行一些增商改查的
修改密码这样的一些操作
也能够基于角色
给这些用户设置权限
这是用户管理的功能
这里就不展开介绍了
然后第二个是
连接器的身份注册
因为连接器
它是要能够
接入到我们数据
进入设施里边
同时也能够
接入到可运数据空间
幅平台的
那连接器的身份
是怎么颁发的
然后以及如何去注册的
可以看一下
我们右侧这张图
它是一个
接入连接器的
一个身份注册的流程图
那首先呢
一些组织的法人
或者个人
向我们的功能节点
这次我把一些
全域的功能节点
和区域的功能节点
我统一的话成了一张图
来简化我们这个流程
我们核心是突出
接入连接器
和我们功能节点
相关的一些交互
所以把他们画在一起
那首先就是各个组织和法人
各个组织的法人
它可以进行连接器的注册
向功能节点
进行连接器的注册
然后呢
功能节点这边
会审批连接器的信息
分配连接器的ID
把连接器的身份标识
给到这个
给到用户
然后个人这边
个人和法人这边
再去将连接器的身份
配置到接入连接器当中
同时
由接入连接器
生成一个可信身份的
请求信息
比如说像
一个证书的请求CSR
然后用户拿到
这个CSR的文件之后
然后再将这个文件
给到就是第七步
把这个可信身份评证的申请
给到功能节点
然后功能节点
它可以返回一个
可信的身份评证
然后用户
我们这个用户
再将可信的身份评证
然后注册到
接入连接器当中
后去这个接入连接器
就可以通过这个证书
和功能节点
或者是和空间服务平台
业务节点
或者是和连接器之间
就可以用这个证书的评证
来去教验彼此的身份
这是第一个就是
连接器的一个身份注册
然后这个注册的流程
就是符合我们
数据纪录设施里边的
关于身份管理
以及身份认证的那个流程
我们就是按照那个流程
来去开发和实现的
那第三个功能
就是可以看一下
连接器和业务节点
他们之间是如何进行
身份认证的
这里边的那个节点
其实它可以是业务节点
也可以是那个功能节点
都是可以的
那这里边流程
可以看就是
首先接入连接器
这个系统
或者这个模块
它会发送连接器的
身份验证求求
主要是包括连接器的标识
和签名信息
这个签名就是
用自己的资料进行签名的
然后功能节点这边
它会先获取
可信身评证
提供商的一个评证列表
就是拿到CA
然后去通过这个CA
去验证连接器的身份
验证之后
会把这个验证结果
反馈给连接器
就是要么通过
要么不通过
如果通过的话
同时这个功能节点
也可以把自己的
区域和功能节点
这个身份请求
然后以及可信评证
和签名信息发给连接器
然后连接器
再用
就是功能节点的证书
去验证
这个签名信息
如果验证通过了之后
然后再反馈一个
结果
给到功能节点
这样就完成了
接入连接器
功能节点之间的
一个双向的身份认证
那第四个就是
连接器和连接器之间
也会做一个身份的认证
这个流程和上面类似
我们可以简单的再看一下
就是这张图里边有一个
接入的连接器A
和接入的连接器B
以及上面有功能节点
那首先就是连接器A
它会把连接器A的身份
评证以及它的签名信息
然后可以发给连接器B
然后连接器B这边
会去从功能节点这边
获取可信身份评证
提供上的跟评证列表
也就是拿到C
然后用C去验签
首先去验证连接器A的
证书是不是由C签出来的
然后再用连接器A的证书
去验证刚才连接器A
发过来的签名信息
这个签名信息是用连接器A的
词要进行签名的
然后连接器B这边
拿到连接器A的合法证书之后
用这个证书
里边的功要去验证这个签名
如果验证通过了
证明它是连接器A是一个合法的身份
会通过
返回一个验证通过的一个结果
给到连接器A
那连接器B
同理也会向连接器A
发送可信的身份评证
和签名的信息
然后连接器A里边
同样的也会先获取到CA
然后验证连接器B的证书
然后再用连接器B的证书
去验证这个请求的签名
如果整个都验证通过之后
然后再去向连接器B
返回这个验证的结果
连接器支持的第二个功能
是数据资源管理
数据资源
我们先看一下数据资源的定义
数据资源指的是
具有创造潜力的数据的总称
它可以是电子化形式记录和保存的
可以继续读取可供
社会化再利用的一个数据的集合
那数据资源管理主要包括
三部分的功能
一部分是叫数据资源介入
第二个是数据资源的管理
第三个是数据资源的目录
数据资源的介入指的是
可以支持介入连接器
所在的机构或者是组织
它本地多种多样的
数据资源的介入能力
包括不限于像对象存储
数据库 本地文件
这些数据源
像目前我们
密算的连接器
是支持了像
Otherbase, AWS, S3
还有MaxComputer
MaxCircle, SFTP, PostgreedCircle等
我们也在陆续的支持
更多的数据源的能力
然后第二部分
数据资源的管理
其实就指的是用户
本地的一些数据资源的注册
更新 删除 修改
这些基本的增善改查的能力
资源的目录指的就是
能够按照我们NDI文件
相关文件确定的
数据资源目录的要求
对已经介入的数据资源
进行描述
形成一个数据资源的目录
同时能够支持本地的
数据资源的检索和查询
这是第二个
数据资源里面
然后我们密算的联系
其中关于数据资源管理里面
有一个特色的功能
就是可以把本地的数据资源
通过密碳的方式
去托管到
我们买密算的
密碳计算平台当中
下面这张图就是
一个数据托管的过程
它大概的流程是什么呢
首先我们看到这张图里面
有标准的连接器
然后就下方
下方是两个标准的连接器
然后上边是我们的
密碳可信数据空间
密碳可信数据空间里面
包括了数据
空间服务平台
以及密碳数据托管里面的
密碳研发平台
那下边的话
这个连接器它是分数据的
提供方和数据的使用方
那首先数据提供方这边
可以将自己的数据
通过加密封装成
这个数据胶能
然后再将数据胶能
可以托管到我们的
密碳研发平台
然后在密碳研发平台中
进行数据的开发
然后加工成数据的产品
然后再将数据产品
在空间服务平台进行上架
这样就可以由数据的使用方
通过数据使用的申请
以及合约的签订
然后能够去申请
数据产品的使用
这个大概是一个数据的
一个密碳托管
然后到数据开发
然后再到数据使用的
这样的一个流程
然后第三个功能
指的是这个叫数据产品管理
数据产品
这简单介绍一下它的概念
数据产品指的是自然人
或者法人
或者是非法人组织
对其合法获取的数据资源
经过一些实质性加工
和创造性的劳动后
形成的
可满足特定拘求的
数据加工品
或者叫数据服务
在可依数据空间当中
数据产品是数据流通
及使用的基本单元
数据的产品从
数据资源封装开发而来
也可以基于有的数据产品开发而来
数据产品承达的形式
可以是数据库的铺表
或者是文件
或者是数据库的API等
这是关于数据产品的定义
联系当中
数据产品管理的功能
主要包括数据产品的封装
数据产品的上架
数据产品的目录
数据产品的封装
指的是
上面说的
可以将数据资源
通过一定的加工
然后封装成数据产品
数据产品上架指的是
可以将数据提供方
已有的一个数据产品
上架到空间服务平台
然后由服务平台代理
向区域或者行业的
功能节点完成数据产品
登记并分配一个唯一标识
数据产品目录指的
数据的提供方
维护本地的一个
数据产品的目录
能够向数据的使用方
提供本地数据产品的
一个检索和使用申请
这样的一个服务
右侧这几张图
分别是
第一个是由数据资源
经过一定的加工和拖延
可以变成数据产品
这是数据资源和数据产品
的一个大致的关系
然后再往下的这张图
是一个数据的
一个上架的一个流程
数据产品上架的一个流程
就是标准型的联系
它可以对数据进行一些
加工与处理
然后封装成一个数据产品
然后可以把数据产品
相关的原信息
可以上架到空间服务平台
然后上架到空间服务平台的产品
其他的标准联系
比如说对一个数据的使用方
它就可以在
数据空间服务平台当中
通过数据产品的目录
能够查看到
已经上架的数据产品
然后可以在
空间服务平台上申请
对一个产品的使用
然后申请这个使用
经过审批通过之后
然后再经过双方的
签成一个数字合约
下面会介绍
就是签数了数字合约之后
然后就是两边
就可以进行一个
数据产品的一个数据交付了
这个是一个大概的
数据产品上架
以及数据消费的一个流程
下面是联系
功能当中的
第四个数字合约管理的功能
在上面介绍数据产品的时候
也简单提了一下数字合约
那么下面我们看一下
数字合约的一个概念
数字合约指的是
数字化形式描述的
数据提供方
数据使用方
数据服务方等
相关参与方对数据流通
使用等环节预期的承诺
包括但不限于数据的内容
使用者
使用方式
使用次数
使用范围
使用环境等
这个数据合约管理的功能
又包括三个字功能
其中包括合约的创建
合约的写商
以及合约的旅行
合约的创建指的就是
数据的使用方发起
数据产品使用
申请时出发的
由数据使用方联系
基于数据产品
要求及服务平台的
使用策略的模板
来创建一个数字的合约
就像我们买方和卖方
一个合同一样
然后用户可以通过
可信数据空间门户
来创建后
下发到数据介入的联系当中
然后这个合约写商指的
就是数据提供方和数据使用方
他们之间可以
就这个使用的策略
然后经过双方的写商
然后最终达成一致
写商通过之后
然后双方在
对这个数字合约进行签名
这里面签名
主要使用的是
各自本地的私要进行签名的
然后合约的履约
就是数字合约签名后
然后数据提供方
数据使用方
然后能够按照合约的内容
进行数字合约的交付
通过数据的使用
来完成一个履约的行为
那么右侧这张图
就是一个数字合约的一个
简单的一个
创建和写商的过程
首先看一下这个
第一步就是
数据使用方
会先在空间扶平台这边
能够看到
所有上架的数据产品
然后可以对
它想要使用的数据产品
进行一个数据使用的申请
这个申请
会由数据的提供方
进行审批
如果它审批通过之后
然后就会产生一个
数字合约
下发到就是提供方
和使用方两边的连接器
然后两边的连接器这边
分别由连接器的用户
对合约进行再次确认
如果对这个合约
里边的内容
确认没有问题的话
那就可以由各自的连接器
本地的私要
来去对数字合约
进行签名
然后这个私要
是由自己本地去保存的
所以这个签名
它是能够体现
是由提供方
它自己签署出来的
这样当双方的合约
军事由各自的
就是提供方和使用方
签字之后
然后会上报
这个签名后的合约
会再次上报
给空间服务平台
然后空间服务平台
这边再会把合约
就是签署之后的合约
再会下发给
这个提供方和使用方
然后最终
就是连接器这边
也会去验证
这个数字合约是否
由双方的私要签名了
如果参与了一个合约的
双方都签字了
那证明这个合约
才是一个生效的合约
就是不同的这个连接器
他们都会用
对方的证书来去验证
这个签名
是不是一个真实有效签名
当这个两边
都已经签名通过之后
这个合约才会正式生效
然后才会走到
下面的数据使用的环节
这是关于合约的
创建和签署的一个过程
那接下来
我们看一下这个具体
就是合约签署完之后
合约生效之后
这个数据交付的一个过程
数据的交付
主要包括三个子功能
一个是交付数据的处理
基于数字合约的要求
对提供方的数据产品
进行预处理
然后对交付的数据
进行加密 拖命
或者是通过隐私保护计算
数据刷箱等方式
来完成这个交付计算的结果
这是关于交付的过程
然后这个交付数据的传输指的是
支持数据提供方
根据签订的数字合约
要求将带交付的数据传输
给数据使用方连接器
这是数据交付里面的数据传输
交付传证者的就是
对数据的处理 传输
还有交付的记录
进行一个日治的存证
并能够将这些存证
上报至服务平台的存证审计系统
来用于行业或者功能节点的
运行监测
同时也能够支持本地的数据查验
这是数据交付需要支持的功能
我们右侧这张
就是我们现在密算连接器
能够支持的交付形式
可以看到我们下边是两个连接器
就是提供方连接器和使用方连接器
当他们签署了一个合约之后
然后合约生销之后
会进行数据的交付
那数据的交付
目前我们支持三种方式
一种方式就是
我们可以直接支持
这种密带的API的方式
将数据交付给对方
另外是可以通过数据集的方式
把数据交付给对方
那第三种方式
就是可以通过隐私计算
也就是NPC的方式
将数据交付给对方
就双方进行一个多方的安全计算
这个主要是我们密算里面
有一个特性就是
一个特色功能
就是基于
我们一有的言语的开源体系
像sigflow circle和psi
这些我们言语
已经支持的一些算字
数据分析和经济学习的能力
我们可以通过隐私计算的方式
来完成这个数据交付
下面我们来看一下
联系提供的最后一个功能
使用控制
我们先看一下
使用控制的概念
使用控制指的是
在数据的传输存储
使用和销毁的环节
通过其成在数据拥用
算法和运用环境中的
一个技术手段
确保相关参与方
按照数字合约约定的
使用策略
对数据进行分析
计算和处理等
实现对数据使用的时间
地点
主体
行为和课题等因素的控制
从而保证
对数据的使用是符合预期的
这里边主要联系
会提供一个是使用环境
就是保证数据
它在交付过程当中
提供的一个
软硬件的一个环境
第二个是控制策略
就是与数据使用环境联动
对使用方的数据使用行为
进行实时的监测和控制
保证数据的使用
符合数字合约的要求
那么右侧这张图就是一个
就是连接器在内部
去实现使用控制的
一个简单的逻辑
首先就是前提条件是
停工方和使用方
已经签出了合约
并合约生效
那停工方联系和使用方联系
会从空间幅平台
第一步会先获取到合约
然后会彼此来进行
数据的交付
交付的过程当中
会产生交付的日制
交付日制会上报
把交付的日制和交付的次数
会上报给空间幅平台
同时就是两方的连接器
也会去检查一下
当前的使用的限制
比如说使用时间
是不是已经过期了
就是合约签订的时间
比如说是
就是2025年的10月
那这个数据的使用的时候
是不是已经超过了
2025年的10月
如果超过了的话
这个合约就失效了
也就是说
在合约签署的时候
这个约定的使用次数
比如说约定的次数是
一万次
那现在如果是
超过了一万次
那这个数字合约
其实就属于是一个
实效状态
或者是已经交付完成的状态
那是没有办法
再次去使用这个数据的
所以会有一个这样的
一个使用控制的能力
好 那我们介绍完
这个连接器的一些背景知识
和连接器的功能
那第三部分
我们会介绍一下
现在密算这个连接器
现在我们大概的一个
技术架构是什么样的
我分别地针对
每一个模块
简单地做一个介绍
第一个是
我们可以先看一下
左侧这张图
这张图里边
主要有四个模块
一个是接入连接器1
和接入连接器2
然后上边是空间服务平台
然后在中间
是有一个密台计算的书扭
然后其中
这个密台计算书扭
是我们就是
密算独有的一个
数据开发平台
是一个密台的数据开发平台
那在这张图当中
我针对连接器
做了一些
这个模块的一个展开
然后其他的
像空间服务平台和
密台计算书扭
这里边就不再展开介绍了
我们主要是
会展开介绍一下
这个接入的连接器
那在这张图里边
就是首先这个连接器
它和空间服务平台
的一些交互
主要是会做一些
数据产品的登记
数据产品的上架
然后数字合约的签署
以及这个数字合约
这个交互状态的上报
还有日治上报
这些功能呢
在上一个环节
其实也已经介绍过了
这里就不展开介绍了
然后连接器和密台
计算书扭呢
需要的交互是
连接器那边是可以把
自己的数据
封装成密台交囊
然后托管给
这个密台的研发平台
然后在密台的研发平台当中
进行一个密台的研发
然后产出一个数据产品
然后再有其他的连接器
进行交费
这个是和密台
研发平台的一个交互
然后连接器和连接器之间呢
是
主要是会做一些身份的
验证
这个是在
上一个章节也介绍过了
就是联系之间可以
会根据
就是数据既有设施的
那一套身份认证的标准
进行身份认证
那联系和联系之间
除了进行身份认证的交互以外呢
它也会做一些
数字合约真正交付的时候的一些
这个协同
比如说在
两边签了一个
通过隐私计算的方式
进行数据交付的
那联系1和联系2
他们会
交互一些MPC
就是多方安全计算的一些协议
然后
两边会协同的
进行一些模型的训练
数据的分析
这是两个联系
可能的第二种交互的类型
就是交互的类型
那我们大概介绍完
就是每个模块
他们的一个交互的话之后
再简单介绍一下
就是每个模块
它大概是做什么的
我们可以看一下
这张图里边
第一个就是有一个web
就是一个web的UI
这个主要是
联系它是一个BS架构的
可以通过浏览器的web页面
然后完成和用户的一个交互
是一个白品的页面
用户可以通过这个页面
进行一些点击
或者是拖拉拽的一些交互
这是第一个模块是webUI
然后第二个
我们看到的这个模块是
叫API Gateway
这个API Gateway
它主要是会接收
来自web前端的
Http的请求
然后会把这个请求
进行健全
然后健全通过的请求
会去转发
给后边的具体的Service Group
然后这个API Gateway
它除了健全以外
它其实也可以做一些trace
一些metric
或者是一些线流
熔断
它是会作为
可以理解为它是
后端提供
就后端服务
它和前端
交互的一个中间的
一个网关
然后由这个网关
会做一些统一的健全
统一的trace
统一的这个熔断处理
这是API Gateway
这个模块的具体的职责
然后再往下的话
就是这里边
有一个Service Group
然后Service Group
它就会包括很多的
功能模块
然后其中
每一个功能模块
它都会有自己的职责
比如说
第一个Connected模块
它主要是
作为连接器的后端服务
它会负责连接器的一些
登记啊
处置化啊
和处理产品相关的
这个SPUD的一些能力
然后第二个模块呢
就是这个
看到的是那个contract的模块
也就是合约管理的一个模块
然后它主要负责
从空间服务平台
会去拉取合约
然后以及这个合约列表
和详情的展示
引起进行合约的签署
因为合约签署
会用连接器本地的
这个资料金签署
这些能力呢
都是由contract的这个模块
去实现的
然后再往下一个
是叫DAG的Converse
就是是一个
有像无环图的这样的
一个DAG的画布
用户可以通过
拖拉拽的方式
去编辑画布
就是像我们一些
传统的这个
积极学习的平台
都是可以通过
比如说通过
这个拖出来一个
数据预处理的算子
然后再拖出来一个
这个模型训练的算子
然后再将这个
就再做一个这个
模型预测的
这样的算子
就是它是一个
可以通过
带个画布的一个编排
能够去完成用户
想要的一个任务流
这是带个画布
它这个solar
它提供的一个能力
然后再往下
是有一个project这个模块
在我们这个
连接的实现里面
会将就是
签署好的一个数字合约
可以绑定到一个项目里面
这个项目可以认为
它是一个工作区
类似于一个workspace
然后用户可以在这个项目里面
进行一些数据的研发
比如说创建一个画布
那project这个模块
它就是会做一些
项目管理的相关的工作
比如说包括这个项目
相关的增山改查
以及项目的命名
或者是合约的绑定
都是由这个模块去完成的
然后再往下看到的是
这个contract
一个delivery
这样的一个模块
它主要是负责数字合约交付的
负责交付的情况的记录
交付的状态
然后上报给平台
这个是合约交付的模块
主要做的事情
然后除了这个院
我们再看到
就是有一个
这里面有一个叫scheduler的模块
这个scheduler的模块
它主要是负责
这个交付任务的调度
它会将这个照片
做一些帮它转换成task
就是主要是会做这种
一些
把带个画布
然后转换成这个照片之后
然后照片呢
它里面会包含多个task
就是一个画布
它是一个有向无关图
那这个图
它会十一画成一个具体的照片
然后这个照片
它是由多个task组成的
那每个task什么时候去调用
什么时候可以去执行
这个task是由scheduler来去决定的
就是scheduler这个模块
去做的事情
然后第二个是
这个
就是cultask这个模块
然后这个cultask模块
它主要是
针对NPC的
协同任务的一个调度
因为NPC
它一般是涉及到多方
进行协同的
那每个
每一方他们
要同时的去拉起任务
那就要由这个cultask这个模块
进行一些协同的调度
这是cultask这个模块
所做的事情
然后User这个模块呢
它就是针对NPC的用户
进行一些登入登出
增商改查
一些全线用户角色的一些管理
是在User这个模块去完成的
然后属于托管工具呢
这个delegation tool
它就是主要是
会做一些
数据的封装
呈密带的胶囊
然后把数据托管给
这里边的密带计算引擎
是由这个模块来做的
然后这个data site呢
它主要是对数据资源
进行一些增商改查的
处理
也许说它
会从不同的数据员
拉取数据
然后对数据进行
一些加密呀
或者是对数据进行一处理
是由这个data site去完成的
然后我看
另外就是可以看到
就是在最左侧有一个log
这个模块
这个log模块
它就是用来记录一些日志的
包括一些交付日志
包括一些人工的操作日志
都是由这个日志模块进行
记录和展示的
另外有一个审计的模块
审计模块就是
它会将日志上报至空间
然后提供日志的
一些审计的能力
然后这里边还有一个
叫inter-gateway的
就是在两边的联系之间
都会有一个叫inter-gateway
然后这个inter-gateway呢
主要是会负责一些
预兼的请求
就是跨越的一些请求
也就是指的是
连接器A和连接器B之间的请求
会经过inter-gateway
去做彼此的交互
所有经过inter-gateway
inter-gateway的请求呢
它会加上彼此身份的
健权获取到的那个token
然后用于发给对方时
对方会根据这个token
会去验证这个请求
是不是合法的
所以inter-gateway它会做一些
联系之间的身份认证
握手然后token的协商
以及会把
两个联系之间的请求
会由inter-gateway
做一个转发
包括像在数字合约交付的
数字合约交付的时候
NPC之间彼此的
这个数据交付
就数据的交付
其实都是通过inter-gateway
做转发的
然后对方收到之后
会验证token
它的合法性
这是inter-gateway
叫做的事情
然后再往下是
有一个
就是sqlter的agent
我们对下面是有一个
部署的底座
它部署底座
可以是k3s
也可以是k5s
就是可以直接
如果你有
就是k3s的一个
基建的pass平台的话
我们可以直接
部署在用户的k3s上
如果用户没有k3s
我们也可以
用轻量化的k3s去部署
轻量化k3s
这个bannermere
它只有70兆
所以它足够的
轻量和足够的便捷
然后再上的话
在这个上面
就是有一个叫sqlter-gateway
sqlter-gateway
它是一个执行的代理
它会负责把
具体的要执行的任务
比如说我们现在
密算的连接器
是已经对接了
言语的里面的
这些算子
包括像言语的
sqlter-gateway的
经济学习的算子
以及这个psi
还有sqlter-gateway的
sqlter-gateway的
数据分析算子
这些引擎
它是由sqlter-gateway
在执行任务的时候
是由sqlter-gateway去拉起的
所以sqlter-gateway
它是
做这样的一个事情
对
就是上面我大概介绍了
我们密算连接器
它的一个
每一个模块
它大概是做什么的
然后以及我们这个
整个架构
它大概是怎么组成的
对
就是我这边
大概就是关于这个
连接的技术架构
大概就分享到这里
好的
那我今天的分享
就到这里了
好的
谢谢大家